Рідкісна нагода зазирнути
у приватне життя канцлерки Німеччини.
Найвідоміший німецький жіночий журнал "Бріґітте"
спробував показати Анґелу Меркель як звичайну жінку.
Канцлерка каже, що її емоції
доволі часто можна легко "прочитати" з обличчя.
Мовляв, вона так і не начилася робити його вираз
цілком непроникливим.
Я здалася.
Я просто не вмію. Мені шкода, але
я цього не вмію...
У такому ж відвертому дусі
Меркель розповідає,
як їй важко впоратися з телевізорами в готелях,
і якою найвпливовіша жінка світу за версією журналу Форбс
є вдома. Перфекціоністкою?
Що ви маєте на увазі:
коли я розвішую білизну, чи що?
Чи коли я мию склянки?
Коли я запрошую гостей,
то так, я дивлюся на склянки проти світла,
чи чисті вони.
Запитання глядачів скеровують дискусію у політичне русло.
Переважна більшісь німецьких партій виступає за одностатеві шлюби,
чому ж партія Меркель ХДС  – проти?
Я би хотіла вести дискусію,
щоби депутати ухвалювали в цьому питанні
те рішення, яке їм підказує совість,
а не керувалися партійною дисципліною.
То як глядачі сприйняли Меркель
у такому незвичному для неї приватному амплуа?
Вона здалася мені дуже відкритою і якоюсь близькою.
Мені це сподобалося.
Були цікаві приватні аспекти. Вона розповіла про свої
закордонні поїздки, як вона в готелі одна дає собі раду –
такого я раніше не чув. Вона справляла дуже природне враження.
Нова сторона, якої я не знав.
Те, що вона вважає красивими
очі свого чоловіка,
чи як перевіряє, чи чисті склянки,
коли приходять гості, - це щось нове.
"Приватна" Меркель сподобалася глядачам.
Черговий бонус чинній канцлерці,
партія якої наразі аж на 14 відсотків
випереджає свої головних суперників
- соціал-демократів.